[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday we begin this half hour with a
new way of experiencing
nature's call visitors and residents in
tokyo are flipping their lids
that's right i said it over the city's
latest attraction
lucy kraft has that story
tokyo's hottest new destination isn't a
swanky restaurant
nightclub or museum said in local parks
the jewel-like cubes are tinted
tangerine pink and purple
and shades of blue-green these aren't
just works of art
they're public bathrooms with a feature
not standard in most toilet stalls
see through walls these are no ordinary
plate glass windows but so called smart
glass
used for privacy in hotels and offices
when the door is unlocked
an electric current unfolds the windows
when the door is bolted the electricity
is switched
off and the windows returned to their
frosted state
see-through toilets were dreamed up by
pritzker prize-winning architect shigeru
bond
i don't think it's crazy visibility he
said is one fix for public toilets which
have a reputation for filth
and criminal activity you need privacy
when you are inside
but when you outside you like to find
out
this is clean and safe right so then it
should be transparent
three times a day cleaners and designer
uniforms ensure the dazzling cubes pass
the white glove test
the privately financed tokyo toilet
project is unveiling over a dozen artful
public bathrooms
but none has raised eyebrows like these
said project manager hayato hanoka
his reaction to the see-through restroom
okay i was super surprised to be honest
he never seen a transparent turret yet
after operating for just a few weeks
users say seeing is believing
you can tell right away whether the
stall is occupied or not i really like
that said this neighborhood mom
the student said going in i was nervous
scared even
but it was fine i recommend it architect
shigeru bond decided not to copyright
his minimalist public laboratory design
he's hoping to spark a transparent
toilet wave around the world
for cbs this morning saturday lucy kraft
tokyo i love this idea but it would be
just my luck i would walk in there would
be some kind of malfunction
i was gonna say as long as it works then
too it's like the different colors too
jeff's not going michelle just he's made
it very clear normal bathroom
will be amazing um all right good stuff
lucy craft thank you very much